each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available so I have a very ambitious uh
plan for this lecture and I'm not sure
will'll fit it all in
um but this is this is some very serious
meat these are these are
uh really powerful and useful
techniques
okay
right so the first technique that we're
going to talk about is uh sometimes
referred to as the far Vector
technique and it unlike everything else
that I'm telling you about it doesn't
have a really clean this is the paper in
which it first
appeared ideas came from several
different papers and and so this is this
is a child of very many
parents
um so we have a database of size n and
we want to answer a very large number of
queries uh but they're a special kind of
query this is going to be an online
algorithm that will answer many queries
so far the only thing that you've seen
is an algorithm that took all of the
queries at once and thought about them
all as a whole and then produced a small
synthetic database that answered all of
them here the algorithm has to work one
by one
now these are going to be a little bit
different than what you've seen before
we're going to have a set as I said of M
queries that are presented online but
only K of them for some much smaller K
are going to be uh called
significant so the queries in general
are going to be sensitivity one queries
and a significant
query is one where the value of the
answer the true
answer exceeds some fixed public
threshold so maybe the number the fixed
public threshold is
258 so the first query comes along it
might be accounting query it might be
some other kind of sensitivity one query
the true answer is um what did I say our
threshold was going to be
258 so let's say that the true answer is
six so the system doesn't say 106 it
says below threshold no answer then the
next query comes along and the true
answer is 700 and it says Ah this one's
significant 700 is much bigger than the
threshold so here's an approximation to
700 it's going to add some noise it'll
be like
722 all right then the next question
comes along the answer is three it says
insignificant below threshold is it
clear so the only thing most of the
queries the promise somehow is that most
of the queries are going to be below
threshold and it won't be saying
anything except below threshold below
threshold below threshold oops this
one's above threshold here's the answer
approximately below below below below ah
above here's the
answer so the promise is that there're
only going to be K significant ones
where K is something like the size of
the database n and that's easily
enforced because this statement of yes
this one is significant is made in
public everybody both the database
administrator and the data analyst can
count how many times that has happened
so everybody will just count up to K and
then
quit uh so again the goal of this
algorithm is to sort of detect and
release values for the significant
queries and the key here is that we are
going to in some sense get the
insignificant queries of which there are
a huge number for free in terms of our
privacy price we're only going to be
paying for the significant
ones so uh I forgot my animation all
right so the first two in this picture
are significant and then you get a whole
bunch of insignificant ones then you get
a significant one and then two
insignificant and so
on so here's our first Tri it an
algorithm when I'm given a
query which is a function f
subt I'm stressing for no particular
reason that this is a general
sensitivity one function think of it as
a counting function a counting query so
if the answer is below the threshold
it's insignificant output this is the
symbol bottom and it says this is
insignificant and
otherwise draw from the lus distribution
and give the noisy answer
answer so the ideas that we're going to
run for up Tok significant queries we'll
choose the parameter to the Lelo to be K
Over Epsilon so that we won't break
privacy and that's that's
it so does it
work what's wrong with this
algorithm
well the first attempt says it's obvious
right we only have case significant
queries so there are going to be at most
K invocations of the llas mechanism blah
blah
blah but you have to be careful this
conditional branch is leaking some
private information there could be a
pair of adjacent
databases where on one database it's
insignificant but on the neighbor we
would just have crossed the threshold
and it would be significant so the fact
that I'm saying it's insignificant is
leaking some
information and the whole name of the
game is going to be to show that that
doesn't actually leak that much
information first thing that we're going
to do I mean so it's clear that because
this leaks private information we're
going to have to add some kind of noise
to it either we're going to add noise to
this and check compare it to the
threshold or we'll add noise to the
threshold that's the same thing because
noise is symmetric it turns
out we're going to do
both um and you'll see you'll see
exactly why in the proof we chose to do
both that will come so the algorithm is
going to take as input the database X
this threshold T that's publicly known
threshold the number K of queries that
you know it's just going to quit after K
queries I didn't put that into the
structure of the algorithm but we all
know that's what's going to happen and
Epsilon so first thing that we do is we
perturb the threshold we choose a t hat
which is um uh close to T and we're
going to blow half of our privacy budget
there okay and then we'll use the other
half of the Privacy budget for the rest
of the proof the rest of the
algorithm so on query
fi we compute a noisy version of the
answer so instead of scaling to K Over
Epsilon we're going to scale to 2K over
Epsilon because we only have an Epsilon
over two left in the Privacy
budget and so if this noisy answer is
less than our noisy
threshold uh then we'll output bottom
and otherwise we'll just output the
noisy
answer
so that should have said utility or and
accuracy all right so what are some of
the things that can go wrong that we
have to watch out for in terms of uh
accuracy and
utility so one thing is we're only going
to answer K significant
queries if when we chose the threshold T
hat we ended up choosing something
ridiculously small then everything might
end up looking significant like maybe
Tad is a negative number very negative
number is extremely unlikely but maybe
that happens and then everything seems
significant and we don't get any utility
out of that so that's going to end up of
course being kind
of very unlikely by the properties of
the llast
distribution another thing of course
that could happen is we could choose the
threshold T hat to be very very much too
big and then nothing would show up as
significant and that's not interesting
it's not a good algorithm and of course
that's not a problem either and in
general we're going to try to prove some
kind kind of an alpha
utility so what we really want is that
we're not very likely to be very far
from the true
threshold and that's uh uh we know that
that's going to be sort of exponentially
unlikely in the degree of farness
okay
um the other place that things can go
wrong is that we so let's assume that we
were really lucky and te hat is
relatively close to tea and we're never
going to worry about that again I mean
we we've taken care of that with our
sort of probabilistic argument all right
so now what can happen is when I add
noise over here something weird happens
so I could get an artificially too
large answer so here f ofx is less than
T hat and less than T and and but my Lao
noise took it over the threshold so
there's some Choice possibility of that
but again that's going to be
exponentially unlikely in that length we
could just get a weird answer so it's
truly over threshold it's very far over
threshold it's extremely Far Over
threshold and when we add random noise
to it we get something that stays over
threshold but it has nothing to do with
the actual value because we had a very
unlucky Choice from the L plus here so f
ofx is in fact way above the threshold
but I get a very bad answer because I
had an unlucky noise that's another
thing that can
happen
um and
uh this has got to be the same kind of
thing
um it's really above threshold I added
big negative llao noise to it so it
shows up as being below threshold and we
missed
it again
unlikely so remember that argument that
we used for Alpha Beta
accuracy uh one or two days ago for the
we made an argument about Alpha Beta
accuracy of the llas mechanism it's
exactly the same argument that we use
here so we're not going to really go
over it in detail we know that with the
definition of Alpha Beta accuracy is
somehow that with probability at least
one minus beta all of our answers are
within Alpha of
reality and so what do we want here we
want to say first of
all if we say at step I that the query
is significant then the value that we
report we want to be within Alpha of the
True Value because we're rep we're
reporting a real number and we want this
to be a relatively accurate real number
not weird noise
effects um we also want that
if the True
Value well maybe if it's not actually
less than the threshold but if it's
we'll give a little bit of slop there
maybe it's over the threshold but only
by Alpha but if the true value is within
is less than t plus Alpha then we
certainly want to say that it's
insignificant sorry so if it's less than
T we want to say that it's significant
we'll relax it a little bit and say if
it's within t plus Alpha we'll say it's
insignificant no I'm saying this wrong
I'm saying this wrong I apologize if
it's
insignificant if it is reported as
insignificant then it shouldn't be much
above the threshold that's what we want
and that's what that says if it's
insignificant then it isn't much above
the
threshold
now we also
want am I making any sense here
I'm sorry what I wanted to say is you
well you're
right the second line is
correct line what what I want to say is
if it is reported as insignificant no no
no no no if this happens then that
happens if it's far below threshold then
we want to report it as insignificant
sorry about that all right so it's
sufficient to get all these that the
conditions when they're correctly
written that with probability at least
one minus
beta the maximum error that we got in
this Lao plus the error that we got when
we're choosing the noisy threshold will
be below
Alpha so in our analysis we'll allow
Alpha over two error here and an alpha
over two error here and then the sums of
the errors will be at most
Alpha
and that will
follow in the usual way
so the probability that the max error
when I choose from either one of these
guys will be bigger than Alpha over2 is
at most by the union bound and the
properties of the L PLO distribution
which you saw already in the previous
discussion of Alpha Beta
utility it's M for the total number of
samples here and then e the minus Alpha
over 2 Sigma by that property in the top
the properties of the exponential decay
of the uh L PLO
noise and similar argument of course for
the for this guy his troubles are very
small compared to his troubles so I
didn't bother drawing um thing so what
we get then is just by manipulating that
Top Line if we take Sigma to be 2K over
Epsilon we end up with this bound on
Alpha
okay so that is roughly speaking the
kind of accuracy that we're going to be
able to
guarantee
and the
interesting question now will be the uh
the Privacy
analysis so the algorithm runs at each
step it gives a response the response
might say insignificant or bottom or it
might be a real number so I'm going to
call the responses that we get in in
round i r sub I so we get a sequence of
responses the response for round one the
response for round two round three and
so on and just the letter r going to be
the name for this
sequence so the sequence of responses is
a random
variable and uh we want to bound the
ratio of the probability of seeing any
sequence of responses when the database
is X over the probability of seeing that
same sequence when the database is the
neighboring X Prime
that's the usual thing we need to bound
and that's going to just be the um
uh the product of the probabilities so
we're getting a sum of the logs of these
ratios where this notation means the
probability that in round R in the round
I we end up seeing little r subi
conditioned on everything that happened
in the previous IUS one rounds and the
fact that the database is
X and here we're conditioning on the
same thing but the database is X
Prime and we want to show that this is
bounded by
Epsilon so this is the quantity that we
need to
investigate yes should I go
back
sorry
this can depend on
previous so I'm Capital RI is the
response that we get in round ey
conditioned on everything that happened
in the
past dep
on
um there is some kind you're right that
there are independent noises being
chosen but there is some kind of
connection because say the threshold was
fixed once at the very beginning and
these guys may all be related to each
other because of that
threshold okay the dependence
is the same yes yes so that rvi is
stating more cleanly what I just said
that the dependence might be caused by
the fact that t hat is fixed the same
for all of them
so we're just going to condition on
that all right so I'm going to take this
sum and I'm going to split it into two
parts one part is the contributions from
the significant rounds and the other
part is the contribution from the
insignificant
rounds the insignificant rounds of
course are going to be the really
interesting ones because there are lots
and lots of them we already know that we
scaled Sigma to handle in some sense
what's going on in the rounds that are
significant so let's just check that if
the round I is significant then a real
valued output is
produced and we have the noise value
that's generated in that round so that's
this draw from the LL
distribution so the contribution that
we're getting to this sum is the log of
the
probability uh that the the noise is
equal to RI this this actual response
that was produced minus fi of X versus
the probability that it's RI minus fi of
X Prime and since these two numbers can
differ only by
one we get the Epsilon over 2K from the
fact that Sigma is scaled to 2K over
Epsilon so that's the usual
thing so just add them all up there at
most K such events the total privacy
loss is Epsilon over two that's not the
interesting case that's the stuff you
already know how to deal
with now we're going to start with the
interesting case
so we're this is where we're going to
use the fact that we randomized the
threshold in here we never used the fact
that we randomized the
threshold so it has to come up now
because this is the end of the I mean
these are the only two cases if we
didn't use it in the first case we've
got to use it
here okay
so fix some x and x Prime and fix the
draw from the Lelo
distribution fix the value of T hat and
because this is an insignificant round
when the database is X we have that f
ofx plus this noise is at most Z we
fixed the noisy Threshold at Z it's
insignificant so it wasn't reported as
above threshold so it's below
threshold okay
so let's look at F ofx Prime clearly if
F ofx Prime is less than F ofx we're
going to also have F ofx Prime being
less than Z that's obvious but what if F
ofx Prime is bigger than F ofx Well we
can't say
that we're going to end up with f ofx
Prime being less than Z but we can show
that it's going to be less than z+
one okay so why is that well we have
that
um I mean it's just obvious sensitivity
is the sensitivity is one so formally I
added this in on both sides so this and
this are going to cancel and over here
it's at most one so we get that so if f
ofx plus this noise value is less than Z
then f of x prime plus the noise value
will be less than Z +
simple so now how do we use this we're
going to introduce a piece of
notation these are the insignificant
when the threshold is z and the input is
x i subz of X so it's going to be the
set of the values of the noise variables
from our draws from the llao
mechanisms which lead to insignificant
for every
I in the set of rounds where we got
insignificant
on X conditioned on T hat being equal to
Z and all of the responses that we got
for the significant
ones
so we
have
this output
here some of these guys gave us some
actual values
so uh I'll use a to mean a value a real
number A1 A2 bottom A3 A4 bottom bottom
bottom and so on so I'm fixing all of
the locations here and
here and I'm fixing these values and I'm
fixing the threshold and I'm looking at
what would give what are are the values
that could give um conditioned on all of
those things what are the values that
could give bottom
here when uh the database is X all
right and the claim is that if a noise
value could give insignificant here when
the database is X and the threshold is Z
then that same noise value will give
insignificant here when the database is
X Prime and the threshold is z+ one
that's because that's that's exactly a a
corollary of this it's exactly what
we're
saying and this is true whatever X Prime
is the adjacent
database
so that's what the claim says
um it's this is just what we said and
the proof is that line right so again
this says that a noise value that leads
to bottom on X when the threshold is z
also leads to bottom on X Prime when the
threshold is z+ one and therefore the
sequences of noise values that
lead uh to insignificant on X when the
threshold is z will all lead to
insignificant on X Prime when the
threshold is z+
one that's what we need for the rest of
the proof so let's go I want to
show that the
product oh sorry I want to look at this
this
product so what is that
well I haven't conditioned on Z here so
I'm going to look I'm going to integrate
over all choices of Z of the probability
that that's what we got for our noisy
threshold times the probability that
these particular that the the the draws
from the llao mechanism will give us
insignificant when the threshold is z
and the database is
X okay so that's exactly
that all right
well this is going to be at most e to
the Epsilon over 2 times exactly the
same
stuff conditioned on T hat being z+
one because the probability of T hat
being z+ 1 is at most e to the Epsilon
over 2 * the probability of T hat being
Z
okay now this set is contained in that
set so this whole
quantity is at
most this whole quantity this guy maybe
a little bit
more so this is bigger than that because
there are more choices over here
possibly more choices maybe it's the
same but possibly more choices over
here great
but you know when everything else is
fixed if a given value gets me over the
limit when the threshold is z + one if I
drop that value and the threshold by one
it'll still get me over the
limit I add a I have a higher threshold
and a bigger noise it gets me
over if I subtract one from the noise
and one from the threshold it still gets
me over so that's what's going on here
we were able to replace this z+ one and
this z+ one by Z and
Z all
right but look at the form of this
it's exactly the form of what we started
out with here only instead of having an
X we have an X
Prime so this is exactly
that
yes what is what small t uh that small T
was um the number of locations in the
that were in
ific with
z
and the history so far and um X so these
are all of the ones that we have to look
at uh the small
I it's the size of I it's the size of I
right okay is that
clear
right yes answer answer a no no no don't
call it an answer because answers are
these actual real values that are
released to the public only when
significant things happen the okay all
right only get trouble
threshold
one yes that's the only time you're
going to get into yes
probity
right that's for one query that's for
one query and the point is we're by by
randomizing the threshold we're finding
a way to take all of these reports of
insignificance and bundle them together
what if I just repeat that
one you would have a little bit of a
privacy loss each
time here we're capturing everything by
this
change and we're only paying
once
okay yes the integral is minus infinity
to Infinity
yes anything
else okay
so just
to summarize what we just showed we have
a database of size n we have a very
large number of queries
altogether we're going to be able to
handle k significant ones and the
algorithm will just turn itself off
after handling K significant ones and it
won't be a surprise to the analyst that
the adversary is turning the algorithm
is turning itself off because the
analyst also can count to K so there's
no information leaked by the algorithm
saying I'm done I'm not answering any
more questions
right the query are sensitivity one blah
blah blah and the goal was to find and
release values for the significant
queries while paying only for the
significant ones the theorem that we end
up with is that it is epsilon0
differentially private and it's Alpha
Beta accurate for this value of
alpha um which again we briefly went
over here and we went over in detail I
think two lectures
ago
good
now how could we do better how could we
get more
accuracy I want to do even
better
sorry exactly I want to I want to
somehow get root K
instead why would I might be able to do
this from the composition theorem
but I have to have something to compose
here I have an algorithm that's standing
all by
itself so let's modify this algorithm
very very
slightly oh sorry about that yeah let's
get to the point let's modify it very
slightly the modification is the new
algorithm is only going to run until it
gives its first significant answer
and then it
quits now why is this
progress well let's just compose it with
itself K times now we have some nice
composable object it's epsilon0
differentially private we'll compose it
we'll run it K times and that's the
answer that's the algorithm gets
repeated K
times so we'll have to choose so this is
before this had been scaled to 2K over
Epsilon
now I'm only answering one so this
becomes 2 over Epsilon but I'm going to
take this whole thing and I'm going to
compose it with itself K
times so I'll need to choose a different
value Epsilon Prime that's suitably
smaller than the Epsilon that I want as
my overall
goal
um let me see did I tell you yeah I told
it on the previous slide so what is that
suitable value
will uh 8 divided by so Epsilon divided
sare otk of 8 K long one over Delta and
then I'll get Epsilon Delta
privacy the accuracy argument just
changes a tiny bit
because we have many uh randomizations
now of the first threshold so we have to
be sure to take care of that in our
proof nothing interesting is happening I
swear to you it's just a detail when you
want to say that you've proved this
thing you have to watch out for that
okay so that is the sparse Vector
technique again it showed up implicitly
in many different ways and
then yeah all
right
yes do you want to answer you have an
answer
well will use yeah right that's
true so the the the only the difference
has to do in re with randomizing the
threshold after
each uh significant
query
every
asked new noise was sampled here but not
here and we need that we need that for
our privacy
proof my ability to collect all of those
events all those insignificant events
together and tie them to the choice of
te
hat uh is really important and when I
compose I have to be able to do that
multiple
times let's talk after because I think
I'm not giving you an answer that's
satisfying you and maybe we can maybe we
can make that more clear later okay
remember the medical cohort application
um cohort that I mentioned yesterday for
looking at concentrated differential
privacy so according to my expert who is
the um Lilla Ono Machado who is the
director of a national Center for
biomedical research at
UCSD what really happens when you want
to form a cohort is you have in mind
some ideal set of patients and you say I
want patients whose blood pressures are
in this range and whose weight are in
this range and this fraction are male
and so on and so forth and she says what
happened and I'm just reporting what she
tells me that typically they don't get
exactly that there aren't quite enough
people of that type so the
researchers like relax their
requirements and say well how about now
with these relaxed requirements and so
on and so forth until they finally get a
relaxation which they feel they can work
with still and the database has enough
people so this is a little bit
like what we're doing with sparse Vector
right the the the analyst says how many
people in the database satisfy this
property or are there enough and the
analyst says I mean the database says no
actually there aren't enough so they
relax their condition and they ask again
are there enough no there aren't enough
and so on but after a number of queries
the answer is yes we're above
threshold so significant queries are
more rare than the insignificant ones so
it's conceivable that we could apply it
in this context but notice the question
mark I don't know for sure I don't know
whether the numbers are good enough that
actually reminds me that there was
something I meant to say yesterday and I
didn't say I hinted toward the end of
the talk at
um that I mean about an idea this of
this kind of concentrated notion of
differential privacy where we relax the
requirement a bit and we say well the
Privacy the probability of having a
privacy loss of K Epsilon is let's say
exponentially small in K squ all
right what I meant what I should have
told you also is
that this behaves under composition
exactly the same way that epsilon0 and
Epsilon Delta behave that is if you look
at the cumulative privacy loss that an
individual suffers over
many mechanisms Each of which is
concentrated differential privacy you
get the same kind of behavior of the
cumulative loss the same bounds on the
cumulative loss as you would have had
had all of them been epsilon0 or Epsilon
Delta differentially private so your
cumulative loss isn't isn't any
worse um
okay next algorithm
um this as it's going to be presented is
an application of the sparse Vector
technique
the theorem
is that you can
answer a whole lot of let's say counting
queries or slightly more generally
linear on linear queries online just
like we did with sparse
Vector uh
and the errors that you get look like
the square root of
n
the square root
of the total number of
queries the fourth root of the universe
size in the log of 1 over
Delta yeah I think that's
right
okay now remember I mentioned two
lectures back one or two lectures back
that it's sometimes useful to represent
the database instead of being a bunch of
rows each row belonging to one person as
instead a histogram over the universe of
all possible databases all possible
people
so that histogram representation
again is a bunch of
counts we have a universe of possible
people let's say if people are
represented by K attributes this
universe has size 2 to the
K and we have some number of people of
type one all their attributes are zero
let's say we have some number of people
of type two some number of type three
and so on up to some number of Type U
okay so we're going to be using that
we're going to think about this Vector
this database as a vector like this
except for one more thing
we're going to normalize it so I'm going
to take these numbers these counts and
I'm going to divide them by n so now
this is like a probability distribution
they sum to one so I'm going to
represent the database as a probability
distribution over elements in the
universe
okay so forgetting about privacy for a
minute multiplicative weights algorithm
is going to give would give us a way of
interacting with something that is
accurately answering queries because
we're forgetting about privacy for a
second so the queries are going to come
in we can think of the queries as being
vectors where the coefficients in each
Vector are just between zero and
one
okay
so if you were asking how many people in
the database have property P you could
look at each of these different types of
people say which of those evaluate to
one make the query one in those
positions and zero everywhere else and
then take the inner product with the
database
so uh this is how we're thinking of our
queries and because we're not worrying
about privacy the response is just this
inner product
okay and what we would do is the
algorithm will maintain some public
estimated histogram XT which initially
will be the uniform distribution just
one
over I lied to you I said divide by n
divide by m the size of the universe so
it's just going to be one over the
universe size in every location that's
this initial I don't know anything um
histogram and we're going to update this
based on the responses so for example if
the
response the true
answer of Ft inner product XT
sorry
if FT in product with the true database
X is smaller than what we get when we
apply XT to the the estimate the current
ly existing estimate which starts off as
the uniform
distribution so XT is yielding too large
an answer then what we're going to do
intuitively is decrease the weight of in
of each element in the histogram where
ft of I is large so because I is kind of
leading in the wrong direction and we'll
increase the weight for each I where ft
of I is small because it's leading in
the right
direction
now uh so that that is how the real
life non-private multiplicative weights
algorithm would
work we want to make a private version
of
it and I'll talk a bit about why it
works after we present the private
version private multiplicative weights
we're going to have a threshold t
bound uh Sigma and some AA less than
one there is going to be an input
histogram just as we've been
describing and the algorithm will
maintain uh a histogram X subt which is
kind of its approximation to the real
database and it's going to start off as
uniform because initially um because
that's what happens in the
multiplicative weights now the algorithm
is going to maintain this but so will
the data analyst X subt will never be a
secret X is the secret but X subt will
never be a secret so when things happen
based on the outputs of the algorithm
both the algorithm and the data analyst
can update that histogram or if you
like the algorithm can keep XT in some
visible public place and it just does
the updates there okay so here's the
algorithm when you're given a query
ft you compute a noisy version we'll
call that ft hat of
X all
right and uh we'll check is it far away
from the
threshold I'm
sorry is
H is this guy the estimate that anybody
could do using the publicly available x
sub T minus one
is it close to this approximation to
truth right ft of X is the
truth it's an approximation because
we're adding some llas
noise and so the algorithm is checking
to see whether this publicly computable
EST uh uh estimate is close to the
approximation we're close to is within
some threshold T
hat right why is it t hat it's going to
be because of the same reason we had to
randomize our threshold in the past this
is some threshold t plus some
noise if
so this is not a significant query what
the data B what the mechanism is saying
is you already have enough information
to compute a good approximation to this
you've got it in XT minus
one that's what the that's the
significance I mean sorry that's the C
antics of the phrase
insignificant the existing approximation
XT minus one is good enough so you just
set XT to XT minus one and that's the
that's the you take that to be the
answer to the
query on the other hand
maybe our approximation to reality is
very different from what's computable
from the public information the public
estimate this becomes a significant
query
so you output this approximation to the
truth and then comes the updating
of the publicly
visible
uh estimate of the publicly visible
distribution this thing that started out
uniform and is getting updated
here is the form of it which just is
really confusing so let me walk you
through
it first of
all okay what are we doing we take
whatever we had before in this position
and we're going to multiply it by e to
the something this a is a parameter it's
less than one all
right uh and then there's this quantity
St ofi and I have to tell you what St
ofi is and there's the form of but as I
said I find it very confusing first
thing is to notice that
because this value is between zero and
one so is one minus that
value okay so this guy is never going to
be negative I'm not sure why I thought
that was so important to tell you but
it's true so you you're going to do
these updatings and you're going to
renormalize uh so what's going on here
in this
case
the you round it to zero and then
that's otherwise you will round it to
zero
sorry well I'm just pointing that out
but I don't I mean I don't understand
for example why you couldn't have raised
the weights of some and lowered the
weights of others and then normalized so
there is a pointer in one of these
slides to your fabulous survey and we
should all read it includ I mean I've
read it but I'm still studying it
um but if you do you want to say more
about this
okay all right so suppose the S what
what this condition says this
approximation to truth that the
algorithm
computed is smaller than what the
estimate gives
you right that's exactly what this says
the estimate is bigger than the
approximation to
truth so in that
case since everybody's weights are sort
of getting lowered and then things get
renormalized lower weights we're going
to lower the weights on the larger ft
ofi more than we lower them on the
smaller ft ofi because we're going to be
lowering them by ft ofi so if it's
bigger we're lowering it more if it's
smaller or we're lowering it
less now if on the other hand the
estimate is small then we're going to
flip it
around and so we will lower the weights
on the smaller ft ofis more than the
weights of the larger
ones so the updatings are going in the
right
direction and then we renormalize okay
so that's the
algorithm why is it
private
I maintain that I don't have to tell you
anything I haven't already told you
about why this is private that you know
the
answer
almost there's one more thing I would
need to tell
you let's assume that I have very few
significant queries why is it
private
have you seen something like this
before I have a bunch of
queries most of them are insignificant
and I say I don't have anything
interesting to tell you that you don't
already
know you could call that
bottom and for the rest of them I tell
you the approximate
answer where did you see that it's the
sparse Vector
algorithm it's exact L the sparse Vector
algorithm and as long as I can argue to
you that there aren't very many
significant
queries this is going to be both
useful and private so first of all we
can of course impose the condition that
there aren't going to be many
significant queries by monitoring and
turning off after some number K of
queries just as we did with sparse
vector and so the only interesting case
question that remains is why is it that
if I answer some you know relatively
small number of if I have relatively
small number of significant queries I'm
still actually able to give you answers
or you can compute answers to lots and
lots of
queries
so the theorem
is that if U is the
universe and remember remember AA was
one of these it was the parameter to the
algorithm here was a over here and here
it shows up in the
algorithm so this this it says that if
there it says that they're are going to
be at most the log of U / Ada squ
updates there are only going to be that
many significant
queries and that's really really really
amazing
well yes the answer is yes now we
can't the answer is
yes there is some incredibly painful
setting of The parameters that will end
up showing you that
you
really
can't get decent accuracy once the
number of queries gets
above uh I don't know not it's like 2 to
the N to the 16 or something like that
so in fact there's a natural stopping
point that otherwise utility goes away
and I'm not going to do that incredibly
painful setting of The parameters um it
still hurts me every time I look at it
and so so your question question is good
and there's this accuracy whatever
tradeoff because of the Privacy
conditions that we have to the gorim
thing said you can't answer two to the
end queries with with
accuracy uh little of n right so we know
we have to stop before we get to two to
the N uh very accurate
answers so okay now I said this is an
amazing fact it also has essentially
nothing to do with the fact that this is
private multiplicative weights this is
just a property of the multiplicative
weights update algorithm all right and
I'm actually going to refer you to this
survey that I alluded to which is just
mind-blowingly beautiful by a Haan and
KH but the strategy for this
proof sorry it's the topic that's the
topic is beautiful but the survey the
survey does it just
it really was very very helpful to
me
so um the technique that's used is a
so-called potential function
argument remember this KL Divergence
that we talked about so at step
T the do you know what a potential
function is have you seen potential
functions so so many of you have not
um
okay do you want to say
more
right that's
true
um have you seen it in that context oh
okay this was
great
all right so our potential function
we're going to have this function that
we
compute more or less I
mean the user won't get to know this
thing the algorithm could know it but
it's really a tool that's just used for
the analysis it doesn't show up anywhere
in the algorithm remember XT is kind of
the approximation to X that's known at
time
T that's right we started started with
x0 which was just uniform and we updated
it after round one round two round three
and so on so the definition of the
potential function the value of the
potential function at Round T is the KL
Divergence which we already went over in
a previous
lecture there should be a second line
here of X with
XT and that's just the sum of x i l x i
over XT of I okay now
this is always greater than zero as we
discussed before from the log sum
inequality so we have this quantity and
it's going to start at some value which
you can convince yourself easily will be
at most the log of the universe
size and the argument is going to show
that this value will drop by at least
Ada
squared at
each
update I'm bothered by whether this is
Ada squ or one over Ada
squ no Ada squar at each update
okay the argument technically actually
shows this that the at time at update T
at the teeth um T an update T it's going
to drop by at least Ada times the inner
product of St and the difference between
the estimate and the truth minus Ada squ
and again that argument is not special
to the fact that this is private
multiplicative weights this argument
shows up in many uh um uh kinds of
multiplicative weights algorithms and
you can see this argument both in the
private multiplicative weights paper but
also in the survey and the papers that
the survey draws on okay so then when
you combine the alpha beta correctness
of sparse vectors and the parameter
choices for T and sigma you end up being
able to argue that with high probability
updates are only triggered when this
quantity the error the true error
between the publicly available estimate
and the truth is at least T over2 and
um
okay then you take the definition of St
and you plug that in here and you do
more parameter oh and you end up showing
that this is going to be at least Ada *
t/2 minus a^ 2 so in other words we plug
this T over2 in over
there and then you do some more
parameter choices to arrive at Ada
squ so as you can see I'm really
allergic to the parameter choices
subtleties but um but the structure is
just the structure of the usual
multiplicative weights algorithms with
just a little bit of extra effort
because of the privacy but you have
actually seen that extra effort that's
exactly what happens in the proof of
Alpha Beta utility um for sparse vectors
for example
yes
uh yes that's part of the pain parameter
choices of T and of Sigma
yes mhm and I'm not going
there
okay see there are these various
parameters and they're all interrelated
in a tight way and it's it's I have not
found a simple way to really understand
it
or and therefore I can have a simple way
of explaining
it okay so let's look at some of what
we've
seen we already talked about using the
exponential mechanism or report noisy
Max to get an offline algorithm for
counting queries you saw that like in
lecture two I
think
um there is a
paper which we will discuss next oh let
let's go here first this is the online
case for counting queries that's just
what we talked
about the next thing we'll do is
we'll get less
specific do we have time
yes yeah we we'll become less specific
and we'll go to arbitrary low
sensitivity
queries the linearity of the queries
played an important role in this in this
argument um it shows up
it shows up here
somewhere and we're we don't have
linearity anymore so I'll show you next
an offline algorithm that handles
arbitrary low sensitivity
queries and then there is also an online
algorithm for arbitrary low sensitivity
queries um which in some sense falls out
of a lot of the techniques that you have
heard of plus maybe one more and um
the only place I know of to find that
right now is Aaron Roth's online course
notes okay so we're going to use another
power tool from
learning and this power tool is called
boosting so what is
boosting at a really high
level it's a general method for
improving the accuracy of Any Given
learning algorithm so for
example this is the example that you
always see in the literature suppose you
have some algorithm that can look at
email messages and does a pretty good
job of classifying whether they're spam
or not it doesn't do a perfect job but
it does a pretty good
job so
then what the algorithm does is it says
let's take this
spam
um
and
let's kind
of use it to handle some
examples kind of forget about those a
little
bit and and look at the remaining guys
the remaining examples that are spammed
that the first guy failed to do
grab some of
those let run the heuristic again or run
a different heuristic with those guys
that handles a little bit more now we're
onun a different heuristic with the
remaining guys handles a little bit more
and let's put them all together so
roughly speaking it takes a base learner
that can receive labeled examples and
outputs a charistic that is pretty
good on the distribution that you gave
it and then you done this many times and
you combine the resulting
heuristics
so procedurally it looks kind of like
this we have a distribution on some set
that we're working with might be email
messages we feed some we feed examples
from this distribution labeled examples
this is Spam this isn't spam so on to a
base learner and the base learner is
going to Output a
heuristic this this heuristic is going
to have the property that it will do
well
on just some constant more than half of
a fraction of the weight of the
distribution based on that we're going
to uh
what right um okay so you feed this to
the Bas learner it gives you a heuristic
maybe if this is the teeth round you've
collecting theistic from the first round
the second round the third round and so
on you have some way of combining them
if the combination is good enough you
say okay we can quit and otherwise if
you can't quit you're going to update
your distribution on say email messages
you're going to take the email messages
that are poorly handled by your combined
thing or by by a you're going to boost
their probability you're going to change
the pro the distribution by boosting the
probability of the unhappy
samples and then you'll start all over
again with this new distribution you're
going to feed it to the Bas learner now
when you Sample When You sample that
you're going to get more of the unhappy
guys the guys that weren't handled well
by the previous one feed it to the bit
Bas learner it's going to do well on
this new distribution and so on that's
the shape of these
things the base learner it doesn't
always have to be this way but for what
we're going to be doing the base learner
is only going to see samples not all of
the distribution that's going to be
important for our particular privacy
proof too but it's true that a lot of
the things in the literature even before
privacy has this and the only
interesting things that we have to do
now in order to say what is a you know a
particular boasting algorithm is say how
do you combine
theistic how do you determine whether to
terminate or not and what is your update
method once you've specified those three
things you have specified your
particular boosting algorithm so again
boosting is a general framework it can
work with samples and in order to
specify the particular boosting
algorithm you just need to say how do
you combine the C istics how do you
check whether it's time to terminate and
how do you
update I'm going to show you an
example just so that it's less abstract
but I'm not going to go into detail we
can go back into the analysis later if
it's
interesting it is multiplicative
weights yes please bear with me and ask
it again when I when I get to the slide
after this one all right so just to give
you an example you have some initial
distribution it's uniform s will always
be a subset of K elements
just for concreteness the combiner could
be the
majority so you have something that
classifies yes or no you produce one of
those at each round the way you combine
is you look and say what are the
majority of the uh of the heuristics say
if the majority says spam then it's spam
then we'll call it spam and if the
majority says it isn't then we say that
it isn't or you could do the median or
something like that okay weight
update
if the thing is correctly
yes oh um that's what we feed to the
base learner we choose a set of samples
from the distribution we call that set s
we feed that to the Bas
learner drawn from d
uh um um you're right well each one is
drawn from D so it's a it's a product
distribution and that's why I wrote D to
the K right but each one is drawn from d
independently okay so the weight update
uh might be that if this thing is
correctly classified by the current
theistic let's decrease its weight if
it's incorrectly classified by the
current uh oh the decrease its weight by
a factor of e which I'm going to call as
subtract one from the exponent so I'm
going to have an e to the something when
I decrease the weight I'm just going to
subtract one from the exponent if it's
incorrectly classified then I need to
boost its probability so that it's more
likely to get fed to the Bas learner
next time round and something may be
produced that is more likely to make it
happen so if it's uh incorrectly
classified I'll increase the weight by a
factor of a which I'm calling adding one
to the exponent then we renormalize so
that's an
example of how boosting can
work
now we're going to do
something really different
we're going
to be applying this to
queries the private multiplicative
weights
algorithm that you saw before was
boosting
people
boosting changing the weights of
universe
elements we are going to be changing
weights on
queries Okay so so it is very different
and it has very different
um privacy consequences which we will
see so our goal is the following given a
database d uh a database which I guess
I'm calling
DB and a set cue of low sensitivity
queries they don't have to be counting
queries I want to produce some kind of
an object maybe it's a synthetic
database but maybe not maybe it's some
kind of generalized data structure
that's why I'm just calling it an
object so that the data analyst when
given this
object can for every query in
Q produce a good approximation to the
value of Q on the database that's my
goal to produce some kind of an object
that
allows uh good approximations to que of
the
database
for now for the boosting algorithm we're
simply going to assume the existence of
a private base
learner that given an
object o will give good answers which
I'll Define in a second on more than
half of the weight of the Distribution
on queries so what does that mean it
means that the probability if you sample
from this distribution on query queries
that you get a good answer good is going
to mean for us that the value that we
get when we apply the query to the
object is within Lambda of the value the
true value of the query on the
database so we want that probability to
be more than by a constant fraction half
of the weight of this
distribution so the probability if I
choose according to that distribution of
getting a good answer should be more
than a half half plus a okay so later I
will wave my hands and say a tiny bit
about the B where the Bas learner comes
from but it turns out you already know
that
too uh so for now let's just assume that
we have a Bas learner that does this and
let's look at our boosting
algorithm so you've seen something like
this before only now we're starting with
a uniform Distribution on the queries
each query has weight one over the size
of
Q and we sample from that distribution
we feed the samples into the base
learner it produces an object a that
will do well on at least a half plus AA
of the weight of the distribution
Yes means you know the answer the answer
oh I'm sorry just get rid of the word
labeled I mean it's just I shouldn't
have had that
there my apologies all
right but I like your I mean you're
right
we we will use the true answers so in
that sense that would be a good use of
the word labeled thank you yeah okay so
it produces an object that's going to do
well on a half plus a of
D and you know at some point we're going
to have stacked up A1 up to whatever
we're going to combine them we're going
to check whether we ah check whether to
terminate the way we're going to we're
going to check whether to terminate if
we do
then our our combiner will be our median
the median of the outputs because we
have we're going to have real valued
outputs now and we're just going to take
their median it's a well-defined
notion um
and if we don't terminate and I'll tell
you the termination condition in a
minute then we're going to update and
that's going to involve this plus one
and minus one in the exponents like I
gave on the previous
example
oh my termination condition I'm not sure
why where it is in the slides my
termination is we're going to run this
algorithm for a fixed number of
rounds that fixed number of rounds will
end up having a form that you know and
recognize by now so deciding whether or
not DET terminate is Trivial and it's
certainly not private everybody knows
how
this is offline anyway just deciding
whether or not to terminate there's
nothing interesting there it's going to
go for a fixed number of
rounds no it's not going to be an
average case analysis but I'm going
to I am going to learn an
object or I'm going to learn an object
that is good for answering lots of
queries for this
database no my query set is fixed in
advance this is an offline algorithm
it's an offline algorithm and I'm going
to run boosting on the
queries okay it's an offline
okay
right that's right as I I said I'm go my
goal is to produce some kind of an
object maybe a synthetic database maybe
a data structure I don't know maybe it's
a little algorithm but it's going to
have the property that once I announce
it to the public world for every query
in the set it's going to produce a it's
going to allow somebody to produce a
good approximation to the quer the value
of the query on the database which you
do by but now you have to right right
but what's surprising here is that the
boosting is being done on the
queries okay so uh right so the question
now is privacy as Robbie said where are
there privacy worries for
us H
privac the Privacy is for the people in
my database I'm constructing this object
o where and and and what I want to to do
is I want
to
uh compo run an algorithm that's
composed of a bunch of differentially
private pieces that I will then put
together with a composition
theorem where are the Privacy risks I
mean you know more or less how the
algorithm works I Told You So this and
the sampling and so on where are the
Privacy
risks
many why is an unasked query or privacy
privac
only my privacy is for the guys in the
database I'm not wor the query said is
public everybody knows what the
questions are in fact they were the
input to the algorithm so what need
where are the Privacy
risks say say that again you're in good
shape go on only the only place
ask quing the original database is on
that step which one this
one in the Bas
learner yeah we are putting up some
queries and we
saying more than half of but remember I
assumed I had a private base learner
that when given a small set of
samples produced something that would do
well on a half plus Ada of the
distribution so I already took care of
that with the assumed private base
learner yeah very good so that's one
place the samples that are being fed to
the base
learner these are sample
queries okay so what's going on yes
there's a there's the issue with the Bas
learner but we handled
that there's the renormalization step
step how the queries get renormalized
depends a lot on who's in the database
because it depends on which things were
answered well which things were answered
well might depend on who's in the
database that will affect the sampling
that's done in the first step and the
whole issue here the reason things are
really tricky is that a single
individual can affect the answers of
very many queries
okay so my presence or absence doesn't
just affect how one query gets
reweighted it might affect how all of
them get reweighted and so my presence
or absence affecting how everything gets
Reed then affects the sampling that's
done at the top that affects what's
getting sent to the Bas learner and so
on so this is really our
struggle
again privacy is problematic because in
boosting for queries an individual can
affect the quality Q of at
simultaneously for many
que so what happens the worry is that as
time progresses the distributions DBT
that we get on neighboring databases
could start to evolve completely
differently and so that distribution
just looks wildly different on
neighboring datab
bases that will affect what gets fed
into the Bas
learner that in turn will affect the
hypotheses that are
generated because the base learner is
working with different
samples so we have to keep the
distribution secret and we can make our
lives a little bit better I mean we can
our lives are inherently a little bit
better because we're dealing with
sampling if we don't have to feed in too
many samples
that will help things a little
bit um but it's still problematic so
that's our that's our
struggle so again
reweighting we want to be similar under
x and x
Prime you should need a lot of samples
from d in order to detect the difference
and we're going to try to arrange that
the adversary never gets its hands on
many
samples that was a lot of
work so the key is going to be very
simple we're going to call it attenuated
reweighting so until now I had said that
reweighting was if this query was
unhappy boost it by adding one to the
exponent if the query was happy meaning
the current hypothesis gave a good
estimate then lower it right and those
are pretty big changes so we want to
smooth that out so instead of saying if
the query is well approximated decreased
by a factor of is is well approximated
decreased by a factor of e we're going
to say if it's very well approximated so
we're going to have some slack if it's
very poorly approximated at then we'll
increase and in between we'll scale
instead of doing a plus or minus one to
the exponent we're going to choose some
number between plus and minus one in a
very natural way we're going to choose a
parameter U and we'll talk about the
choice of you later but it'll be kind of
chunky and what we're going to do is
we're going to scale with the distance
of the midpoint between um so this is
the error here things where the error is
less than
Lambda those are good things where the
answer is more the error is more than
Lambda plus mu that's going to be bad
and in between so these are going to be
this is going to be the plus one Guys
these are going to be the minus ones and
for everybody else we're going to scale
with the distance to the midpoint of
this interval so the distance to the
midpoint divided
by this chunky factor which I haven't
told you yet called
V so this chunky factor is going to take
something which is kind of high
sensitivity and it's going to scale it
down one person's presence or absence
won't affect what happens to this
particular query CU by one it's going to
affect it by at most 2 times the
sensitivity divided by
mu okay
okay so I'm I'm scaling it
down um let's go back to this in a
minute right sorry that should be
last my animation wait you can't see
what's going on
sorry
okay so remember this is the form of our
algorithm in each round we're taking K
samples we're going to run the base
generator to get a synopsis for every Q
we're going to run the attenuated reting
which I just described and that'll give
us a new
distribution and our output is the
median
so let's think about oh can't see it
very well let's think about what the
Privacy loss is per
sample well we saw that we showed that
for every sampled
query the
sensitivity
was 2 * row /
mu mu is our attenuating factor that we
put in there
okay so let's just say that that's a the
order of 1 over mu we're going to treat
each sample as a kind of differentially
private mini
mechanism and we're going to use
composition to show that in each round
given that we have fixed the history the
total privacy loss is going to be on the
order of K to the 1/2 K is the number of
samples this is where we're using
composition K to2 divided mu because the
sensitivity for any one is 1 over mu and
I've got K of them and I get to use that
square root of K from the composition
theorem rather than K times it plus K
over mu^ 2 that also comes from the
composition
theorem
okay
so the total privacy loss in this
particular round will look like K to
the2 divided by mu and we'll choose
things so that K to the 1/2 over mu and
K over mu^ 2 are about the same now it
will turn out that for an accurate base
sanitizer we need something like we need
to feed about end samples that's I'm
just telling you that this is
true
and in order to
but if our error is as big as into the
1/ half that will give us
privacy so if
the so we're going to feed to the base
sanitizer K queries we're going to get
something which on those queries
is going to be accurate to within n to
the 1/2 and in fact on many queries is
going to be accurate to within n to the
1/2 which
is good enough to give us
privacy and it's uh non-trivial accuracy
because the maximum error could be
in so this number is so
small that we could even afford to
increase this by a small polinomial like
n to the one6
and that will allow us to control the
cumulative privacy loss over all t-s of
our algorithm by increasing me just a
little
bit so the algorithm the theorem that
you end up with is
that we choose me to be well how many
rounds are we going to have to run this
thing by
arguments similar to the argument that I
didn't tell you for the multiplicative
weights update previously it's the same
kind of argument it's going to be log of
the size of Q divided Ada
squ and
then we have to throw so this is how
many rounds we
have I forget why we Square it we're
going to throw in square root of K
because we have K samples per round and
this is the thing that we divide by with
of course our
Epsilon
okay so the only thing I didn't tell you
is how to get the Bas
learner and the Bas Learners come from
uh previous
work if you were only handling counting
queries
then it turns
out that if I
feed
about on the order of n queries if I can
take n queries I can compute their
answers and there's a little tiny
database oh where did you hear about
these little tiny databases before for
counting queries from the Blum lied and
Roth result so there's a small database
that will answer the selected queries
well then there's an argument that says
because this is small it actually has
what's called good generalization error
which means that we chose these queries
at random we produced something that
answered these queries well but because
it's somehow very compact we haven't
overfitted too much and it's actually
going to do well on most of the queries
or in a big chunk of the queries so
that's what happens here for arbitrary
real valued things we do less well we're
going to do the same kind of thing we're
going to choose these about and
arbitrary queries
we're going to fit an N element database
to it we know there's at least one
because the original database is that
good but we fit an N element database to
it and we're going to get bounds that
are less
satisfying still interesting but less
satisfying and the reason for the
difference is related to the size of the
alpha net that you need for handling
handling arbitrary query sets versus
counting query sets you saw the alphanet
before in the Blum leget and Roth that
was for counting queries and uh your
alphanet has to be bigger for arbitrary
queries okay
so that is what I prepared for this
morning so we went over the sparse
vectors where we had these K queries I
mean this large number of queries but
not too many of them were above
threshold we only paid a privacy price
for the ones above
threshold
then we used that for private
multiplicative weights that leted us
answer lots and lots of counting queries
with pretty good
accuracy and that introduced the sort of
the idea of boosting but it was being
done on Universe
elements then we switched to arbitrary
queries went offline but used boosting
again this time for the
queries okay very ambitious
day